en este suburbio al norte de París los
carteles señalan la cancelación de la
celebraciones por el día de la bastilla
y tampoco se festejará uno de los
principales eventos Beach menil el
gobierno local planea utilizar el dinero
que se gasta normalmente durante la
fiesta nacional para pagar la
reconstrucción de los disturbios en
varias ciudades aquí solo uno de cada
dos habitantes puede permitirse tomar
vacaciones por lo que estos niños
afirman que no celebrar festividades
como esta los dejará sin nada para
disfrutar durante el verano
estoy muy triste de verdad tenía muchas
ganas de ir me hacía mucha ilusión
el alcalde considera que la cancelación
de eventos ayudaría a ahorrar dinero
para pagar los daños causados por los
manifestantes
cancelando el evento podemos ahorrar
hasta 300.000 euros asistirán algunas
personas que no tienen nada que ver con
los disturbios pero viven en esta ciudad
no estamos castigando los residentes
estamos pidiendo responsabilidades pero
a los habitantes les cuesta aceptar el
giro que ha tomado este 14 de Julio
tengo un hijo con autismo y necesita
divertirse es un castigo pero no tenemos
opción no podemos subir de ello
para los que aún no han hecho nada ni
tienen la oportunidad de unas vacaciones
es una lástima la oposición considera la
decisión del alcalde como
contraproducente para la ciudad ahora
que la situación se calmó es más
importante hablar con los residentes
establecer una conexión social con ellos
y comprometerse con la gente
el alcalde aseguró que el resto de
actividades al aire libre se
desarrollarán con normalidad numerosas
ciudades al norte este y sur de Francia
también cancelaron sus fiestas del 14 de
Julio por temor a nuevos disturbios